VADIM SOLOVEY: The
company called TabTale.
They do games for kids
for mobile devices
like iOS or Android.
They want to release a
new game every two weeks.
So if you look
from the technology
part of that equation,
this is something really,
really challenging.
With Google Cloud Platform
and Google App Engine
specifically, it actually
means that they can deploy
new versions of the back end.
They can support more games.
And that's wouldn't be
possible without something
like Google App Engine.
We have that unique
methodology of-- we
call that "transformation
in 21 days."
And actually that means
that we take the customer
from where they are and move
them to Google Cloud Platform
and providing them with some
real results in just three
weeks.